what do you think is the primary driver
of human civilization is it the desire
for sex love power or immortality like
avoiding uh the fear of death
constructing illusions that make us
forget about our Terror over mortality
so sex love power death
is this a Twitter poll it's a four
options this is reality not everything
it Maps perfectly to a Twitter poll but
in this case because there's four
options and it is a small number of
characters it does but I'd like to think
I'm more interested you know what
I think your Twitter polls are
fundamentally interesting there's
something about the the brevity of a
poll limiting to a set of choices and
having an existential crisis and
searching for the answer
that's beautiful that combination well
this one's a big one like what do you
think is behind it do you believe that
there is one primary driver like do you
think that it can be understood in the
terms of primary drivers
yeah I think well maybe it's an
engineering perspective like trying to
reverse engineer the brain I don't think
we're equipped or understanding enough
about the mind to get there yeah like
what's the primary driver of a tree
yeah well then it gets the question of
what is life what is a living organism
to self-replicate probably that's a very
clean simplification but
I think life
is more interesting that
than just self-replication yeah but it
sounds like you there's a curiosity in
you that you're trying to like poke at
and I don't understand exactly what that
curiosity is so if I if I had to
dedicate a thousand years to understand
one of these topics which one would be
the most fruitful I guess is the
indirect thing I'm asking
no well fun after to me everything is
fun but I feel like yeah yeah I mean I'm
with David Foster Wallace the key to
life is uh to make sure that everything
is on borrowable it should be
unborrowable or ever nothing is boring
everything is fun
every like everything I'll could just
literally sit I honestly because I don't
think I don't know where you got that
glass but that glass exists and I forgot
it exists it was really fun to me to
know that now is there but it felt it
really things
like if you're in like a deep agony
yeah that's fun okay that's fun because
it's like I mean yeah heartbreak is like
knowing that I'm capable of that it it
like from
uh you know we're all living in the
gutter but some of us are looking up at
the stars so when you're in that gutter
for some reason the stars look brighter
right like so like whenever you're going
through a difficult time
or whenever you see maybe other people
being shitty to each other it makes you
like really appreciate when they're not
the contrast makes life kind of amazing
I'm reading a bunch of books one of them
is Brave New World where they remove
Contra you know where they remove the
ups and downs of life
um partially through drugs but over over
sexualization all that kind of stuff and
I feel like you need
that Contra you need the ups and downs
of life
uh the dark you know you need the dark
to have happiness to have like a deeply
intense feeling of affection towards
another thing or a human being yeah yeah
so everything's fun but fun is also a
weird word to Define because fun I think
for a lot of people in
like that's why I talk about love a lot
I I think I think love is a better word
than fun
because fun is like light-hearted
love is more intense
like I love that class and the water
that's in it because it's freaking
awesome like somebody made that glass
right like they and like not have many
mistakes and like there's a and the way
Ben's light in interesting ways and the
way water Blends light in interesting
ways like I can see part of your arm
through that water
that's freaking amazing everything is
amazing
I'm with the Lego movie anyway
um if but if like from a scientific
perspective if I were to investigate sex
I don't know why I put love in there
let's just narrowed down the Twitter
poll let's focus on the basics here sex
power or death immortality
if I were to try to
like from a neuroscience neobiology
perspective or reverse engineer through
building AI systems that focus on these
kinds of Dynamics exploring the gang
theoretic aspects of it uh exploring
the sort of cognitive modeling aspects
of it which one would get me to a deeper
understanding of The Human Condition
that's the question sex
okay Nietzsche is the will to power
uh Freud and and the bunch is all about
sex
and then
um death
uh live just uh live Burley
brilliant previous guests on this
podcast she just released a video where
on her bedside was the book denial of
death
uh by owners Becker which of course you
would have on her bedside but that the
his whole work is that everything is
motivated by our trying to escape the
the cold harsh reality that we're going
to die and we're terrified of it one of
the gifts and burdens
for human beings is that we are
cognizant of our own death
and that terrifies us that's the theory
and because of that we do everything we
can we build we build Empires to escape
the fact that we're mortal wouldn't this
change quite a bit for religious people
then who don't believe that they're
going to die well they created religion
the idea there to create myths religions
you can create religions of all kinds
like yeah but if this is like one of the
defining things that
Define civilization then we should
expect to see like massive differences
between people who believe we're going
to die in people who don't good I love
it you think of like a like a
scientifically here but uh and they have
actually answers like there's a whole
Terror management Theory where they do
type write psychology type papers and
they do actual experiments I can mention
how their methodology is interesting
um they Prime with the discussion of
death like they take one certain set of
people and have a conversation with them
another set of people they mentioned
death to them before the conversation
and see how that affects their uh the
nature of the conversation it's really
interesting because death fundamentally
Alters
the nature of the conversation just even
priming the con like reminding you that
you're going to die briefly changes
changes a lot of things these kinds of
priming papers usually not replicated
I just have like I feel like I've heard
a bunch of priming ones that
I think you have PTSD over psychology
papers it's not replicated I just did
one I just did a primary experiment on
my own and found it didn't have any
effect
but again can't you just give me okay
Carol a statement summarizing an entire
scientific discipline of Terror
management Theory I don't know uh I
think people should like I haven't
rigorously looked at how good of it
psychologically I think okay it is
interesting philosophically the way
Freud talked about the the subconscious
mind philosophically it's an interesting
discussion then you have to get rigorous
with it for sure
um but
the idea is that
like it's not that religious people
get rid of the terror of death
this is just one of the popular ways
they create an illusion on top of it
that's that idea like a myth that allows
that makes it easier for them to forget
to escape that Terror but everybody else
does different
different methods like
you feel your days with like capitalism
has a whole it's a whole religion of
itself like the rat race for getting
more and more material possessions and
so on and couldn't you argue in the
opposite direction like let's say assume
that we're Christians here and we're
like oh the atheists you know everybody
has Terror of hell and the atheists
invent this mythology where you know
actually evolution is true in order to
escape their Terror of hell so it
doesn't feel like a persuasive argument
to me but I used to be very very
Christian and I did not have a terror of
death and then I lost my faith and then
I had a deep Terror of death set in for
a few years and it felt very different
to me so for denial of death I don't
know if he says that it's actually
possible without
really a lot of work to get to the
actual Terror like I think his claims
that in early early early childhood
development
that's when the terror is real
and then we come aggressively construct
systems around it of social interaction
to to um
to support to sort of construct
illusions at the top of it I'm doing a
half-assed description of this
philosophy but there is like it isn't
interesting to simplify
the human mind into underlying
mechanisms that drive it yeah I was
gonna say your thinking seems kind of
poetic like the way that you're sort of
handling these yeah these Concepts feel
like more like aesthetically driven I
think this theme is going to continue
throughout this conversation as we talk
about relationships and sex yes for sure
I think so and I think you're thinking
seems to be very driven by how can I
construct an experiment
to test this hypothesis yeah something
like that yeah but aren't there's some
things especially that have to do with
the human mind that are really messy
really difficult to understand there's
so many uncertainties and Mysteries
around that we don't yet have the tools
to collect the data like one of your
favorite tools is the survey is asking
people questions
and then figuring out different ways to
indirectly get at the truth because
there's flaws to the survey and you you
kind of learn about those flaws and you
get better and better asking the right
questions and so on but that's not
that's indirect access to the human mind
but do you think like Poetic narratives
are I'm not like saying poetic
narratives are bad like I think it's
like a cool way of like handling
Concepts but I'm not sure that they are
more rigorous no no no okay no but like
they might be
the more correct like philosophy might
be the right way to discuss things that
were really far from understanding yeah
I mean they might be more useful
shorthand yeah like morality like I
don't think morality makes any sense but
it's really useful shorthand to use when
handling Concepts and a lot of the time
right like ethics and morality you could
construct studies that ask different
questions like uh you know just having
worked with the autonomous vehicles a
lot the uh the trolley problem gets
brought up and I don't know you can
construct all kinds of interesting
surveys about the trolley problem but
does that really get at some deep
moral calculus that humans do it's sexy
because people like write clickbait
articles about it but doesn't really get
to like what you value more five
grandmas or like three children or
whatever like they construct these
arguments of like if you could steer a
train if you could steer an autonomous
car which do you choose
yeah I don't know I don't know if it's
possible with some of those to construct
like sometimes the fuzzy area
there's some topics that are fuzzing
will forever be fuzzy
given our limited cognitive capabilities
I don't know there's a way of looking at
things where it's like for example the
childhood fetish thing that I was
talking about like departed your
footages come from like you can develop
a narrative where it's like you know I
think like this kind of thing is you
know you're surrounded by feet when
you're a child this causes foot fetishes
um and this is like kind of a cool
narrative uh and I think a lot of
people's ideas about philosophy follow
the same sort of thing like what is the
narrative that is cool and I think this
is useful for meaning making like I'm
very Pro meaning making like when you're
talking about everything is uh fun
because you know the contrast or
whatever I've very much just ascribed to
that I really enjoy that that philosophy
I also find everything to be very
delightful uh but and this isn't like a
question of truth right we're not like
where is the true Delight that we're
objectively measuring I guess there's a
frame a poetic frame that you're using
to like sort of change the way the light
hits the world around you and that's
super useful because it like makes you
happier
or something
yeah but also gets
to the truth or something
yeah I guess what is the truth
um yet another question what is truth
you've uh
you've actually to jump back you don't
blue you believe that Free Will is an
illusion um
so uh
why does it feel like
I'm free to make any decision I want
well it's a cool illusion I think it's
probably like where a sense of identity
oh like when you really meditate on your
sense of identity for at least for me it
seems like it comes down to the sense of
choice like oh I am doing the thinking
like what does it mean to do with
thinking it's like ah something in me
has
exerted agency over having this thought
or not having this thought
like the sense of self really comes down
to choice and so when I say that like
free will listen illusion I also mean
there's something like the selfish
illusion identity is
a trick of the light
but it's a really fun one yeah you think
a lot about your identity
I have occasionally yeah like you really
struggle with it you're proud of it I I
do too it's not we have different
Journeys but so I really take a lot of
delight in it I used to be very into
like deconstructing it like you maybe
you know I did a bunch of like way too
much LSD for a while and at that point
very no no ego and now I'm like very ego
I really enjoy having a lot of ego
I actually happen to know like
everything about you really yeah like
more than you do it's interesting that's
fascinating wait could you could you
solve my problems yes all of them I've
did thorough research okay
um
what is consciousness then
I actually wrote that as a question what
is consciousness
to remind myself so like uh how's that
tying together with Free Will and
identity and all of that it doesn't mean
what his Consciousness is like one of
the biggest questions ever I think I I
do think that people often get confused
when talking about Consciousness because
I think people are referring to two
separate Concepts and often like
combining them into one thing like we
asked the question you know is AI going
to be conscious
um I think this is kind of the wrong
question like uh like like we can
identify signs of Consciousness like ah
they seem to refer to themselves but
this is not necessarily proof of
Consciousness in the same way that like
dream characters
acting exactly the way normal human do
people do in your dream is not evidence
that they themselves are conscious so
like signs of Consciousness are not
proof of Consciousness but there is
something that we definitely know which
is like I currently am conscious I can
tell because
right like I like I'm like just directly
observing my experience yeah uh and so
like there's one kind of Consciousness
which is I am directly observing my
experience and that you cannot replicate
it like there I cannot observe two
experiences uh it is necessarily
singular and it is necessarily certain
like you can make all the arguments you
want like I'm still directly observing
it's not a thing that's subject to
reason whereas are other things
conscious this is something that's
replicable like you can apply it to
multiple people
um it's something that's not certain uh
like almost definitionally not certain
like we don't actually know if there is
you know an internal experience so my
argument is that like when people are
talking about other things having
experience they're using a different
concept than the thing that they're
actually looking at when they look at
their own experience I think they're two
different things
definitionally not possible no if you
understand the mechanism of
Consciousness you'll be able to measure
it probably right yeah but what are you
measuring like I think this is like a
subtle difference like when you're
asking the question it's other thing
conscious
yeah the easy thing to measure is like a
survey does this thing appear conscious
yeah and then the hard thing is you
understand the actual mechanism of how
Consciousness arises
in the physics of the people do that in
a dream presumably like if you had a
very good dream or a very good
simulation yeah but we could then have
somebody in a simulation or a dream
where they go through and they fully
understand you know they do all the
tests and the tests come back exactly
they'd expect them to uh but from the
outside we're like well this is
misleading they're not actually
conscious
like your dream characters aren't
conscious right probably I don't know
are you asking are you telling I'm like
appealing to an intuition
but it sounds like you're driving
towards a narrative I don't you you did
a poll about men and women and Dreams
yeah those are some kind of difference I
couldn't tell what the difference was
except that more men than women quite a
lot more women dream vividly than men oh
which actually found my chaos surveys
like I did a survey maybe you know that
I said I don't know everything you do
know yes I'm sorry so as you clearly
know I'll try not to talk down to this
conversation because I don't know and I
not only know everything I know how your
future looks like really and every how
everything ends yeah so you could
probably win all the prediction markets
on my life yeah cool so well we should
also mention that you have like
prediction markets uh you have like
votes that you what what's the site
called again manifold manifold and one
of them was will I be on the Lex
Friedman podcast yeah and I voted I
invested everything I own into the yes
is there such thing as
I think inside attorney is part of the
information so that's supposed to be and
then I realized it's actually public
information that I voted because like I
think my face shows up there's like damn
it it's gonna influence
you could make the fake account or I
could be lying right yeah and then dump
the stuff you know I try to manipulate
somebody made a market like is Ayla
going to post a poll spelled p-o-l-e on
her Twitter like a photo and I was like
I'm gonna manipulate this market so I
like [__] around with it and I voted
no and I accidentally posted a photo of
a poll without thinking
sabotage yeah I accidentally yeah the
fact that my own Market that doesn't
that's like the reverse of Insider
training yeah uh what were we talking
about oh the women and the men and the
difference the vivid dreams
and the markets I forget what the market
oh because I can I can perfectly predict
your future yeah then it's not fun I
like the romance of unpredictability and
so I I like to even though I know
everything I like to forget everything
yeah very very Buddhist of you yeah the
river no no man in the river once
whatever the footsteps however that's
one of my uh favorite questions is like
if you could press a button and then
have all of your wants fulfilled
anything that you want so it's like such
a rapid degree that you don't really
experience the one like as the wander
Rises it then is like completed
immediately so that you are completely
without want like would you would you
press that but 100 not yeah I didn't
think you would no no you know because
immediately everything stops being fine
the first it's only fun the first time
but if you want it to be fun but like
what would be my source of fun I feel
like I would like on day four just to
get off I would need to like do like
nuclear war because it'll escalate
quickly
I feel like if everything is possible I
assume you mean like something that like
is not just normal human things yeah
magical world magical world then you
start escalating really quickly
like I wonder I'll probably do like I
want everybody to just fly into the air
and hover in the air
everybody and then you're like oh
life is meaningless like why does like
you you go I feel like you get
uh uh no I actually that'd be a really
interesting experiment like what are the
limits like are we all capable of
becoming Psychopaths essentially
like
I like to believe not there's a very
hard limits on that like in our own mind
like of basic compassion because I love
being compassionate towards other human
beings there's one of the things I think
about if you give me power like a lot of
power like absolute power and I think
that's the power you mentioned is the
scariest kind of power because it's like
it's not even power in this normal world
it's like magical power where you lose
it's a dream world power where you like
video game Power you don't even think of
it as reality you could just mess with
the world I feel like that's terrifying
yeah basically be God
yeah but without like
I feel like the idea of God wants to
like gonna keep things like
functioning properly but then you would
probably if you wanted to keep them
functioning properly yeah then it would
rapidly like you would never experience
a time where you're like oh no that was
a mistake because as soon you like
before you even experience that the
world would shift to to match it oh
interesting now I think I would actually
I take it back I think I would regret
the first time I hurt somebody
see in my visualization was like a video
game where everybody's like NPC really
dumb no I think the first time I I
witnessed paying from anybody that's
when I would stop and I would probably
run into that very quickly
like even just the hovering make a
person hover and they're gonna be
probably really upset with the hovering
right and so I'm gonna be like no don't
do that anymore and then I'll probably
go to honestly I'll just return back to
my normal life
uh yeah that's kind of what I feel like
like if I had the power to do anything I
think I would probably want to have a
life very similar to where I am now yeah
yeah I mean there's it's like with Uber
like it'd be probably more convenient to
do certain things
but even then
like the struggle like I got a flat tire
so I have to fix that I kind of the flat
tire makes
makes everything more beautiful was that
cool I could do like a normal manual
thing
uh but also it makes you like appreciate
your car appreciate Transportation
appreciate the convenience the
transportation all of it I I know some
people who would like call this a bunch
of copium like you're just sort of
making do with what you have like we
wouldn't go back to Homage times or like
pre-technology because to like in order
to make ourselves appreciate things more
and so this seems like a hindsight
reasoning uh which like I can appreciate
that argument but I don't know I'm like
anyone who uses sorry to interrupt the
word copium in their um in their
argumentation
um uh I think it's sauce
yeah it's that's my entire argument and
it's now no I'm just kidding I'm sorry
go ahead sorry I interrupted rudely the
flow of thought uh but you you see you
don't think so in part you disagree with
that kind of argument
um
yeah because I I think people have this
idea that if you uh like come to accept
or like Find meaning in what you have
now this is sort of at odds with trying
to improve it
and all right I don't find this to be
the case I find like the attempt to
improve it to also be part of it like I
enjoy the fact that there's something
like problematic going on because now I
get the experience of like striving to
make it go away and like that in itself
is where the meaning lies it's not just
that things are bad it's that there's
things are bad and we're trying to stop
it and also exactly there's if you
combine that with a sense of optimism
that the future can be better yeah that
feeds
feeds into this productive effort of
making things better
and it somehow makes the vision of the
things that are better more intense
having experienced shitty things
yeah
so we talked about Free Will and
Consciousness and what drives human
civilization question left unanswered
it's a homework problem for the reader
okay
let's get like a scoreboard at the end
the amount of questions the answer
successfully versus not like polls yeah